thank you for the warm welcome
I'm just feeling the love
congratulations graduates in class of
2019 so last year the class this speaker
was Hillary Rodham Clinton this year you
got me and so and so I want to start by
telling you how sorry I am
and by the way considering the last
three years I imagine it must have been
refreshing for last year's class to hear
from a politician who is an actual adult
[Applause]
to hear from a person who is a tickle
aid experienced thoughtful literate
measured and with an adult's vocabulary
[Music]
it's been ten years since I was here in
graduate school I wasn't always happy
here for reasons having to do more with
me than with Yale so it wasn't a lit was
me but I wouldn't change any of it it's
good to be back and to be reminded of
spending hours in articles bookstore and
getting dinner at the Indian restaurant
that my husband and I loved and
attending seminars in professor
Thompson's house which was full of
objects that he collected in central
Africa in the 1960s and there was also
the slightly awkward seminar I took on
African literature in which my own novel
was part of the curriculum
I just sat there and said nothing and I
wasn't sure what to do with my face but
most importantly being here
Yale afforded me many opportunities to
engage in that activity that is
essential for a fiction writer
eavesdropping I did it in the library in
the gym by walking a little too close to
people in the hallways and for a writer
almost nothing is out of bounds if it
leads to collecting material for fiction
and Yale having such a wide range of
interesting people I mean just look at
your hats the material I collected here
was absolute gold thank you so much
possible I'm very honored and very happy
to be your class day speaker thank you
for inviting me I know you're all
excited to be graduating and while I
congratulate cyou I also want you to
know that it only goes downhill from
here when I graduated from undergrad I
felt on board the structure of
expectations was gone no more classes to
attend no more papers to write and the
world felt wide open disorienting
dizzying I was full of contradictions
and I was in a battle with myself about
my contradictions because I did not know
then that it is human and okay to have
contradictions I was full of uncertainty
and I did not know that confidence is a
journey a continuous journey and not an
absolute destination and I want to tell
you this now to save you years of
figuring it out yourself there are days
when you will be bursting with certainty
and days when you will be flattened by
doubts and it helps a little to keep in
mind how universal this is there are so
many things I said I would never do when
I was younger and I now do many of them
I would give you detailed examples but I
don't want to unnecessarily alarm you
the point is be open to changing your
mind
it is often a sign of growth be open to
the possibility that you might be wrong
ideology is a good thing but if you find
that you heal unquestioningly to every
orthodoxy of the ideology you subscribe
to then maybe it's time for some agility
in your thinking a small shift for
example a sign that shows that you know
that they're complicated shades of grey
everywhere I would suggest in general
that you marry being idealistic with
being pragmatic and it helps to think of
Puritanism as too expensive as something
you cannot afford so politics is awful
in all sorts of ways but refusing to
participate is not the answer sometimes
you have to get in there to be able to
walk towards changing it to what you
want it to be engage with the wall
that's as it is otherwise you won't
really get anything done but as you do
so it is important to have as your
guiding light a clear vision of what the
world should be I think of my writing as
my vocation it is what I am on earth to
do but there are people who know me not
for my writing but for my speaking about
feminism
I did not set out to be a feminist icon
and I'm still hoping that somebody will
make me a hat that says feminist icon I
happened to have a platform from my
rights in and I happen to feel strongly
about justice in general but the
Equality of women in particular and I
began to use that platform to talk about
what mattered to me and it happened to
resonate with people who already were
thinking about the same things it also
happened to irritate quite a few people
I remember a man who spent a lot of time
trying to explain to me why his wife
always had to submit to him I was a bit
confused about why anybody would be so
insistent on the idea that the rightful
place for a fellow human being was a
place of permanent subjugation why would
a well-balanced person need another
person to submit the world is full of
people like that man is it necessarily
my responsibility to educate them know
do I want to yes why because I think
it's worthwhile to give people most
people the benefit of the doubt because
I think it's worth trying to change a
person's mind if that will lead to a
greater human good and because full
disclosure I happen to have a mild case
of a Messiah Complex I want to change a
small slice of the world so will trying
to get a man to see the full humanity of
women mean that he might for example
stop justifying domestic abuse
maybe maybe not but I want to try I see
it as trying to walk towards making a
small slice of the kind of world I want
to live in I have a dear friend who
lives in Lagos
her name is bossy she's an utterly
brilliant and humane gynecologist and
she has a daughter who clearly inherited
her mother's genes this daughter grew up
in Nigeria and was then sent to private
secondary school in the UK she excelled
and she was a top of her class in every
subject and so they were recently
thinking about where she would go to
university and because I deeply admire
the American liberal arts curriculum I
told her that I thought she would
benefit from going to university in the
US rather than the UK her response in a
very calm
sixteen-year-old voice was I don't want
to go to America because I don't want to
die the starkness the directness of her
wards threw me off for a moment
obviously she meant guns her mother
later told me that she had been
particularly scarred by the video of a
white policeman shooting a black man in
the back there is a figurative ebo
expression for a certain kind of unease
a disruption a troubled Ness that
expression is ephemeral and it
translates literally to things are not
standing well
the awkward beauty of this expression
things are not standing well best
captures my sense of America today to
say that things are falling apart
Oh half fallen apart mic sound as though
one is susceptible to melodramatic
exaggeration but things are not standing
well wherever you might be on the
ideological spectrum things are not
standing well if fear is in the air that
Americans breathe I bring this up
because I want to suggest that as you
graduate in this time that you ask
yourself the question what should
America be should America be a country
where fear is always an option for
children in school where a child can go
to school and never come home because
that child has been murdered by another
child with a gun should America be a
country where black people live in fear
of their lives because members of the
police do not seem to think of them as
full human beings should America be a
country where women are in fear of not
having full autonomy over their bodies
is a country still a full democracy if
fear is in the air its citizens breathe
should America be a country of Patriots
people inspired by love and pride or
should it be a country of nationalists
people inspired by hatred of enemies
many of those enemies real and many more
invented what should America be
conceptualized that America and then
make the case for that America not only
in obvious ways such as how you vote but
also in smaller ways how you treat other
people how you think of other people the
things you refuse to condone
the people whose grievances you refuse
to dismiss the acts of kindness you do
the people you choose to listen to and
to hear and truly hearing people can
often be the best way of showing them
that they matter so going by historical
precedent a Yale degree makes you more
likely than the average graduate to
become president or a senator or a
Supreme Court judge a Yale degree makes
you more likely to become a person who
in different capacities will be
responsible for policies and actions
that will affect the lives of millions
of people no pressure
by the way this is proof if we ever
needed proof of how fair America's
unimpeachable meritocracy is not the
point though is that a Yale degree will
open doors there are people who will
resent you for having a Yale degree but
there are many more people who will
accord you the automatic assumption of
competence if your degree does end up
propelling you to power remember that if
power were a jacket it is most
flattering on all body types when worn
very lightly if you end up working in a
non-profit remember that the best
charity is that which does not
perpetuate itself never forget that
human beings actual human beings with
dreams and hopes and fears with pride
and favorite foods and things they
dislike and like are the focus of your
charity numbers
sistex language can sometimes make the
real humanity of people invisible and
sometimes people you expect to be
grateful for your charity will not be at
least not in the way you want or expect
because it can be complicated to be the
recipients of charity if your job
involves traveling around the world
remember that local knowledge is always
best yes read the country reports
written by the CIA or whoever writes
those reports but place a higher value
on local knowledge local newspapers
literature the person who picks you up
from the airport and if you are one day
and robed in corporate power and some of
you here certainly will be please hire
women as executives are not just in
human relations
change corporate culture have an on-site
daycare make paid family leave standard
ordinary if you find yourself with power
in the world of journalism banished
forever the practice of false
equivalence journalism should be about
the truth not about balance if you're
reporting on the facts that climate
change exists you don't need to bring in
a hack to show the other side because
there is no other side and if you do
become a journalist please learn how to
say I'm sorry
journalism seems to be a profession
whose practitioners have great
difficulty in saying I'm sorry
without hedging or equivocating and
speaking of saying sorry knowing how to
say I'm sorry and mean I'm sorry will
serve you well no matter what costs your
life takes and if you are one of those
people whose tongues seem unable unable
to form those words I'm sorry there is
hope practicing in front of a mirror
helps don't change the subject
don't pretend that nothing happened
don't buy a gift and deflect don't ride
it out in silence hoping it will go away
just say I'm sorry a few times if
necessary and of course it helps if you
actually mean it but please do not ever
apologize for existing or for taking up
space in the world or for having a
well-considered
opinion and I say this particularly to
women who's socialization teaches them
teaches us to shrink ourselves as though
our responsibility is never first
to ourselves but always to others and we
end up sometimes feeling guilty for
wanting the things we want for wanting
to be our own selves first the messages
that society sends us can be conflicting
that tension between telling you to
value yourself that you matter and then
that other message that tells you to put
other people first and to serve it is
possible it is necessary that you find a
balance between the two but you will
have to figure it out yourself but if I
can offer a useful guiding principle it
is this you do not have to make room in
your life for people who wish you harm
so one enduring lesson I learned here at
Yale is always to look at primary
sources first and I've held on to that
lesson it is I think a useful lesson
especially in this age of easy outrage
when so many people are quick to react
to an isolated port or sometimes
received second or third hand so I once
read a book review and based on that
review I decided not to read the book
because it didn't sound like my sort of
thing many years later I read the book
because I was at a writing retreat and
it was sitting there on a shelf and I
thought I would just read one page and
then I couldn't stop I loved it and I
could not believe how that reviewer
could have so mischaracterized that book
so if you choose to participate in the
cult of the outrage of the day on social
media and if you're quick to jump in
with your blistering take and I
understand that the adrenaline boost
can be addictive but before you jump in
the fray look at primary sources first
and remember that context is always
Queen this is also I think a good way of
testing your own beliefs take a little
time to find out what was actually said
or done and if you have context then
maybe maybe you might just start to
question what you thought you knew
having said that I do sometimes worry
that American education has created a
class of brilliant talented people but
people who are nonetheless afraid to say
the wrong thing even in ostensibly safe
spaces if the walled inside of college
was safe then you should know that the
world outside of college is not and I
urge you always always to honor the
doubts that you have are not the
questions that you have don't silence
yourself so I want to tell you about a
conversation that happened among a group
of people recently people who were
acquaintances if not friends but who all
generally were on the same side and I
might or might not have been
eavesdropping on their conversation so
they were talking about a politician and
one of them said that the politician was
a racist because that politician
supported school choice another one then
asked tentatively but how and the
response from everyone else in this
group was a lot of eye roll in a lot of
sneering and then finally one person
gave a treatise on how supporting this
politician was just supporting racism at
the end
nobody had explained why support in
school choice was horrible and there is
a valid argument to be made for that
position but this young person was left
not knowing what that argument was and
perhaps also left feeling heavier with
several layers of shame I worry that the
space is occupied by the educated in
this country have become places where
curiosity is considered passe it is now
an environment where everyone is already
supposed to know supposed to guess it
and those who don't
has seen as morally lacking if there is
a lesson here it is that you should
always remember that a self-righteous
sneer is not an argument don't be that
person who attacks or demeans because
you are unable to convince I know that
the idea of bringing receipts is a thing
in your generation it would have been
nice if someone in that group had
brought receipts make the argument
clarify explain
do the walk cite statistics if you need
to and bring the damn receipts when I
started out writing I was doing what I
loved what gave me the greatest joy and
I hoped also to be read and today I feel
grateful to be read to be taken
seriously to be here my walk is very
important to me it's central to my life
but the moments of greatest joy for me
are not necessarily those that have to
do with my success and so please not
sure your ambitions seek to be
successful but keep in mind that there
are hollows that success will not be
and yes this is where I talk about love
I have a Swiss friend who once lived in
DC but now lives in Zurich
and I asked him what he had made of
America when he lived here and he said
Americans don't have friends because
they are too busy working he meant I
think people who live in America whether
citizens or not and so I urge you class
of 2019 to prove him wrong have friends
many friends or just one friend hold
your family close and family doesn't
necessarily mean those to whom you're
related by blood or by social
institution hold your friends clues
stand up for your loved ones tell the
people you love that you love them tell
them often find reasons to laugh
gravitate towards people with whom you
never feel that pressure to perform or
to be what you're not one of the tenets
I try to live by is never admire quietly
if I admire something about someone I
let them know we do not always recognize
what is beautiful in ourselves in our
spirits until somebody has pointed it
out to us and remember that people will
hardly ever forget small acts of
kindness
I remember once during a public event I
was exhausted I was a little grumpy
actually I was very grumpy and I was
surrounded by people none of whom seemed
to see my exhaustion and then my friend
and then my friend Sheila who was there
sort of looked at me and said she's
tired and I almost burst into tears
because I felt so wonderfully seen be
kind paying attention is one of the most
beautiful acts of kindness the people
you will come across in your life will
not forget when you are kind and they
will not forget when you're unkind I
wish you well as you go out into the
world I wish you courage I wish you joy
and of on a final note as you navigate
the world it might be helpful from time
to time to forget that you went to Yale
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]